hey will oh you weren't because I want
to make a little announcement no don't
hold on a second yeah don't make okay so
all right hey hi Brian haha is funny I
was late because Brian did send me one
class and I pulled in huh and the and
the girl there at the desk was just
befuddled at the mention of the fighter
in the kid yeah but it did make me smile
first of all she brought one you don't
know Bryan Callen in person yeah no and
then today so I thought that was funny
and then so I don't really give a [ __ ]
yeah you know what I mean it's alright
that I'm it's alright that I'm you know
that you sent me to the wrong [ __ ]
place you know I'm already I already
drove forever from where I [ __ ] hey
I'm from so that's not a big deal and
you know what we are good friends and
you know another thing Brian we've been
late to each other [ __ ] for a long time
because we're good pass on time and we
used to do a podcast together years ago
and I think we had we might do another
podcast together and we've mentioned
that on the program here in the tamanna
podcast with our good pistol you and I
might just do a podcast together and I
wanted to go through what maybe maybe we
could figure out what we're gonna do
yeah but here's my guess okay yeah but
here's the thing though dude yeah yeah
so let's just get it out on the table
and ten minute podcast we used to call
it peeling the onion yeah get to that
pearly malleable soft you know melt in
your mouth middle middle of the onion
and just be be transparent Brian and I
had been talking about doing a podcast
together but but but you know don't
don't tell everyone every no I just
thought we brainstorm see what should we
what should our podcast be about because
I had some ideas well I mean they look
can i bounce some ideas off you yeah and
you won't be shitty no I'm not gonna be
shitty I'm just saying cuz I'm just
bouncing ideas and I don't like when
you're shitty I'm not [ __ ] your shitty
something now you're kind of drumroll in
a pretty hard aren't you but you're
already doing shitty now yeah no no I'm
not doing shitty all I'm all I'm all I'm
trying to say is don't don't promise
people cuz you have a you do have a very
loyal audience that I'll tell you and I
would like to say this on wax here on on
fighter in the kid when I get
messages from people that say hey bring
back that podcast and do this or do more
that I really appreciate that stuff and
I and I know that there has but there
are people that have listened to the
whole you know tamanna podcast canon
yeah and there's and there's talk about
reviving I've heard online this is
exactly online online people say that
this talk of that game or that we we
might there's no rumor there's people
saying that would be fun if you did that
yeah that's a route there's rumor yeah
okay call it rumor call it what are you
going to happen anything could [ __ ]
have you can have I could get up and
plant my left foot in on the bridge of
your nose and not hey into that oh and
not that ugly a stupid [ __ ] medieval
grandfather clock that you have for some
reason oh why do you have that you don't
come into my studio and start
threatening physical stuff because I'll
tell you something right now yeah well
right now yeah right now right okay you
come at me yeah yeah yeah what's gonna
happen I don't know what's gonna happen
but I do know one thing for sure right
you know for sure that I'm gonna I'm
gonna mean don't fall asleep don't
through that mmm that's very
disrespectful wait look at this if you
do you know what that is what that's me
in deep REM sleep dreaming of you trying
to come out not agreement okay you wait
hold on this is what I look like when
I'm asleep and I'm dream see out here
I'm gonna show it to you again
ready this is how I've severe sleep
apnea already
then this is me not breathing for a
minute and a half and then here's the
part where I dream of you ready and then
it goes getting purple no oxygen
definitely having a stroke watch the
world record from Will Sasso two minutes
18 seconds no oxygen and then more
dreaming you get the picture oh my god
so how am I going about what would
happen if I came at you I don't know
what would happen will I but if you come
at me
I know one thing 100% for sure right
you'll [ __ ] your pain no you'll [ __ ]
your pillow
[Music]
no I want you insulting son of a [ __ ]
if you come at me I'll piece you up I
mean that PC up is that something Brian
okay okay okay gig is up
yeah biggish I meet you you meet a mish
meet now my I don't mean me no I'll meet
you halfway
yeah I'll meet you halfway yeah so
that's all I can guarantee that I'll
meet you halfway
Brian we cool cuz the ground is coming
at you quick right now the grounds
coming at you Craig right and you might
want them you might want to pull your
pull my what your chute right your shirt
right pull my pull the rounds coming at
you quick yeah it's coming at me quick
so your mana at this point right now
yeah yeah at this point right now yeah
yeah yes I'm I'm loose all right feel
good right so a little hot yeah right
yeah not some caffeine gone okay right
your little exam and
I'm feeling strong yeah and quick yeah
right yeah
so you might want it what my one or what
crowds coming at ya I wanna tell me
getting me halfway
are you sure I'm not pulling those shoes
and I'm not pulling I'm you know I'm mr.
Crowley and that's fine it's coming yeah
yeah it's coming real quick you know
what you're drooling now you [ __ ]
drool on your shirt yeah because I'm cuz
I'm foaming at the [ __ ] mouth no cuz
you're a beheading cow your [ __ ] hand
drooling with the cud and its own 10th
mill huh you were trying to suck your
own beats and got beheaded
um I don't wish you any ill physically
ok so that's why we can't ever fought
alright yep cuz those eyes cuz you're
heading toward a wall no you know what
you know what we have toward a wall
you'd you might want to yeah why I put
on you into an evil beast from them from
an M night Shyamalan huh I twist your
head completely around separate all your
joints so that your arms and legs at the
knees go backwards and you'd be like
crawling up like on a wall or something
with it somehow can or until like that's
what I'm gonna tell like I'll lighten
Magic's a so and I'm gonna turn you into
a horror movie villain well until I
counter so anyway we were thinking about
doing a podcast but what I'm gonna say
to you Brian is don't promise these
people anything that you can't deliver
I'm not promising because when and I'm
now I'm really gonna peel the [ __ ]
onion when when it comes down to 10
minute podcast yeah that's three
separate entities and it's a whole it's
pretty hard to get ahold of three people
to do one thing especially when one of
those people is in outer space
that'd be Chris D'Elia you know I hope
he hears this because he's [ __ ] in
outer space
he went into outerspace sure did that
guy is into shoes his new chain he wears
a new chain I thought he was kidding
coffee me too yeah I look at Chris
Thalia and I go like this sometimes
right to his face ago I can't believe
I'm with you
he texted he texted us that picture of
the chain yeah and you you knew that
this was real so as soon as I was like a
hat what and then you were like oh no
that's real that's real okay so anyway
getting three people together is is like
getting him from outer from off of Mars
yeah in from outer space yeah you got to
pull him by the oxygen tube that's
hooked up to his space helmet yeah Tom
tough because you'll cancel on you right
quick if we're just gonna like talk
about [ __ ] yeah yeah we shouldn't yeah I
don't know that we should share that
outlook but a tough but I tell you what
why I [ __ ] it man you know what I'm
bored you know yeah let's do it let's do
it I would love to do another podcast
called Chris is it it's in outer space
Chris in outer space
yeah it'd be very um I was thinking we
do a podcast about hmm dreams like hmm
what just like everybody's got a what
does everybody have what does everybody
have yeah everybody what does everybody
have a mind of soul yeah but what else
what do they have what they have what is
every person [ __ ] has what a sentient
existence yeah but they what else they
have and everyone carries body [ __ ]
eyes you know a right to be here to be
in this town not really not everybody
some people should be killed rights and
we know that okay but what had everybody
just what everybody how was it
yeah everybody just has like you know
just like a life like life inside of
them okay okay you're getting close to
it a life inside of them not everybody
actually so chris is a little bit dead
behind the ice right it doesn't have
life behind he has I won't drink coffee
my dude you know that kind of stuff
right but but but what does everybody
including even Chris have I don't know
huh a dream wrong yeah you know I mean a
dream I'm gonna cut you off right yeah
this is a bad idea
no but not maybe not maybe the podcast
is about helping people realize their
dreams so we start with like
affirmations like this like like how
amazing would this be if we're like hey
guys this is the will and Brian show I
don't know what's a good name maybe
dream big podcast big dream big
podcast and if you guys want it then
really want it and you know we start
with an affirmation like that mmm okay
that's I'm not trying I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to like you know grind
things to a halt dude but I really am
okay I'm [ __ ] bored okay well it's
not a good idea that no no it's not
because your idea I'm just you know I'm
just bored now yeah I just got bored
whoa all right right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]